[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv 78 nous
sommes le mercredi 30 octobre voici les
titres de cette édition une période
difficile pour les stocks de produits
sanguins avec les vacances scolaires les
prochains jours fériés le début des
épidémies saisonnières résultats des
donneurs sont moins nombreux et les
réserves s'amenuisent un appel à la
mobilisation a été lancé par
l'établissement français du sang
elle a reçu le soutien de la première
édition du loto du patrimoine la villa
viardot à bougival sera restaurée et les
premiers travaux de rénovation de cet
édifice en péril du 19e siècle ont été
lancé officiellement hier
coût total du chantier plus de 3
millions d'euros enfin demain c'est
halloween l'occasion de ressortir votre
plus beau et déguisements on vous donne
les tendances de cette année reportage
dans un magasin spécialisé à maurepas l2
invite également tout à l'heure en
plateau en parlera du vaccin contre la
grippe qui peut être effectué dorénavant
chez votre pharmacien
et puis il en use your bird 7a à
villepreux il est spécialisé dans le
domaine de l'immobilier
on commence avec cette information après
la fusion avortée avec renault fiat
chrysler dont le siège français est à
trappes discuteraient d'un rapprochement
avec psa
une union qui ferait des deux groupes le
numéro quatre mondial du secteur
automobile chez psa qui est implanté
dans les yvelines à vélizy poissy et
carrières sous poissy la nouvelle est
plutôt bien accueillie fo premier
syndicat du groupe souligne un projet
attractif et mais sera tout de même
vigilants sur la suite des événements
écouté il à attractif parce
qu'aujourd'hui mon psa est un groupe en
bonne santé financière
et puis il vaut mieux demain est un
groupe de dimension à vendre notre
millions de véhicules que quatre comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
on sait que les rapprochements entre
constructeurs peuvent amener je dirais
et certaines synergies et je dirais la
mutualisation de certains métiers donc
il faut qu'on reste vigilant ce qui
concerne l'activité sur les sites
il est ainsi que sur l'emploi
vacances scolaires week-end prolongé de
la toussaint en approche une période
forcément difficile pour l'établissement
français du sang les donneurs se font
rares portage au sein d'un lieu de
collecte c'est à viroflay avec manon
varaldo tout est prêt à viroflay pour
accueillir les donneurs les réserves de
sang sont fortement impactés avec les
vacances de la toussaint et les jours
fériés du mois de novembre
les donneurs sont moins disponibles
chaque jour férié est un jour de
collecte en moins mais pour les patients
les besoins de poches de sang se
poursuivre
c'est les urgences et la chirurgie c'est
l'accouchement avec les femmes enceintes
le plus important c'est des personnes
qui ont un cancer et qui sont traités
avec de la chimiothérapie ou de la
radiothérapie
il y a aussi les hémophiles assez aussi
donc toutes les matières maladies
hématologiques les grands brûlés c'est
aussi les drépanocytaires c'est une
maladie génétique
il y en a beaucoup en ile de france la
durée de vie des produits sanguins est
limité 5 et 7 jours pour les plaquettes
et 42 jours pour les globules rouges
pour donner son sang il faut avoir 18
ans peser au moins 50 kg et être en
bonne santé ce monde en paix tu dois
donner parce qu'il ya des gens malades
n'osant pas tomber malade à n'importe
quel moment peut être victime d'un
accident alors si on ne le fait pas
bajur y aura pas un don de sang ne prend
aucune heure dont seulement une dizaine
de minutes pour le prélèvement
cette trentenaire donne pour la deuxième
fois son sens le temps de s'enregistrer
puisqu'il ya plusieurs étapes de voir le
médecin et après 2
donner son sang même pas une heure je
crois ça peut aider des gens et nouba ça
nous coûte rien après leur don une
collation est proposée aux courageux la
prochaine collecte de l'établissement
français du sang est prévue le samedi 2
novembre à saint germain en laye de 13
heures à 18 heures à la salle de
réception de la mairie et pour donner
votre sang justement plusieurs collectes
mobiles sont proposés dans les prochains
jours dans les yvelines vous l'avez
entendu ce week end déjà des deux dates
samedi à saint germain en laye dimanche
à mantes la jolie
la semaine prochaine le fs propose de
donner au théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines située à
montigny le bretonneux collecte
également dans des communes plus rurales
au mesnil saint denis le mercredi 13
novembre
rendez vous le dimanche 17 novembre
c'est à limay a monté son pardon c'est à
settat bailly pardon voilà by his vous
le voyez à s'afficher sur cette
infographie pour connaître les
conditions pour donner aussi les lieux
de collecte fixe consulter le site
internet de le fs période peu propice
pour les dons du sang mais très
favorable au virus de la grippe il sévit
depuis le début de l'automne entre 2 et
8 millions de personnes pourraient être
concernées cet hiver pas des billets
d'épidémie encore en ile-de-france
rassurez-vous la tendance est au vert
sur toute la région vous le voyez sur
cette carte du réseau sentinelles m et
la campagne de vaccination a débuté
depuis le 15 octobre elle doit se
poursuivre jusqu'au 31 janvier
et nouveauté cette année vous pouvez
faire votre vaccin chez votre pharmacien
bonsoir ohnona djallit en soir alors
vous êtes pharmacien à rambouillet vous
êtes le président de l'ue et rhdp est
pharmacienne de france et l'union des
professionnels de santé
alors c'est ministère de la santé
injustement qui a simplifié est la
procédure pour les personnes majeures
elle était en test dans quatre grandes
régions de france l'an passé est étendue
donc sur tout le territoire à partir de
cette année comment vous l'avez
accueilli comment les formations ont
accueilli cette nouveauté va d'abord
c'est la suite logique de
de l'acte de dispensation du vaccin et
c'est l'objectif c'est de raccourcir le
parcours de soins c'est à dire faire en
sorte que qu'on enlève toutes les freins
possibles à la vaccination parce que
vous savez qu'il y a environ dix mille
morts tous les ans dus à la grippe donc
c'est quelque chose d'important mais il
est important que l'on se vaccine avec
le vaccin qui convient qui est refait
chaque année ça sauve des vies
le vaccin absolument ça sauve des vies
en tout cas c'est fait pour ça tous les
vaccins sauvent des vies et il est
important que cet acte de vaccination
deviennent presque une une habitude et
que ce soit vraiment une
une vraie volonté de tout le monde de se
faire vacciner alors pourquoi le choix
de raccourcir du coup ces délais de
vaccination pourquoi il s'est porté sur
les formations
pourquoi c'est eux qui ont été choisi
d'abord parce que le pharmacien est un
professionnel de santé de premier
recours que les médecins les infirmiers
étaient déjà évidemment dans la boucle
depuis de nombreuses années et que
malgré les efforts de tout le monde et y
compris de l'assurance maladie
on ne dépasse pas les 50 % des personnes
cibles c'est à dire des personnes les
plus sensibles à savoir les personnages
et les personnes immunodéprimées et les
femmes enceintes
un certain nombre de patients qui sont
éventuellement avec des pathologies
lourdes dit à élise etc et donc il est
absolument nécessaire que ce taux de
personnes vaccinées augmente et s'était
demandé par les pharmaciens il était une
fin le pharmacien donc jamais demandé
mais il est normal et logique que le
pharmacien à un moment puisse participer
à cette action de prévention vous savez
que c'est très important la prévention
c'est ce qui évite les maladies c'est ce
qui évite les coûts supplémentaires
c'est ce qui évite aussi dans le cas
présent un certain nombre de morges les
dix plus de 10000 tous les ans donc oui
c'est quelque chose
encore une fois pour raccourcir le
parcours parcours faciliter l'accès à la
vaccination de façon à ce que le
patiemment patients non parce qu'ils ont
en tout cas la personne qui veut
faire vacciner puissent accéder à cette
vaccination beaucoup plus rapide avec le
principe du sans rendez vous on vient
son rendez-vous dans les pharmacies pour
faire ce vaccin
la campagne a débuté depuis le 15
octobre quels sont les premiers retours
justement des personnes qui viennent se
faire vacciner dans votre pharmacie à
écouter d'abord la dispensation de la
vaccination est très très accéléré cette
année habituellement c'est aux alentours
du 15 septembre
là on a un mois de décalage mais un mois
de décalage qui se prolongerait après le
début janvier et que on est environ
en tout cas des chiffres que j'ai pu
avoir entre 15 et 20% des personnes qui
demandent une vaccination en officine
est-ce que ça demande une organisation
particulière justement alors on prend le
cas de votre fils in à rambouillet voilà
avec vos salariés
alors évidemment d'abord c'est pas tous
les salariés c'est que les pharmaciens
qui peuvent vacciner il y a évidemment
une formation obligatoire aux gestes et
aussi à identifier les risques et puis
il faut avoir un espace dit de conflit
en réalité parce que évidemment qu'on
peut pas se faire vacciner devant tout
le monde donc dans un espace clos
et donc un certain nombre de matériels
je tiens à dire quand même quelque chose
d'important c'est que plus on sera
nombreux à pouvoir vacciner plus on
pourra augmenter le taux de vaccination
l'objectif n'est pas de faire à la place
des odm et avec les autres olivier le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que le public
cible on est à très peu de vacciner un
argument si vous voulez y des contenus
pour valider le ms considère que l'on
doit être entre 75 et 80% de taux de
vaccination auprès des prescripteurs
sensible et je vous disais tout à
l'heure qu'on a du mal on est en dessous
de 50% donc il est important que tout le
monde participe à cet effort de
prévention et je salue évidemment cette
cette nouvelle façon d'accompagner la
prévention merci renaud naji d'être venu
le dire sur ce plateau
merci à vous je rappelle que vous êtes
pharmacien fait de vous vacciner
le message est élancée pharmacien à
rambouillet vous êtes le président de
l'uar ps pharmaciens ile de france la
campagne de vaccination contre la grippe
est ouverte jusqu'au 31 janvier toutes
les informations sur le site de l'
agence régionale de santé et direction
bougival à présent ou la villa viardot
va subir un lifting la demeure de la
compositrice pauline viardot construite
dans la commune des impressionnistes
était à l'abandon depuis des dizaines
d'années la pose de la première pierre
du chantier s'est déroulé ce mardi et
avec l'ensemble des mécènes sur place
michael et demi d'euros le coup d'envoi
des travaux de restauration de la villa
viardot à bougival a été donné la
première pierre du projet a été posée ce
mardi 29 octobre
un soulagement pour les défenseurs de
l'ancienne demeure de la compositrice
française
c'est une immense joie ce sont dix neuf
ans de combat qui aujourd'hui sont
soldées par cette belle journée
où on va enfin restauré ce haut lieu du
patrimoine
objectif des architectes réparé dans un
premier temps les extérieurs le projet
prévoit ensuite de créer un centre de
documentation sur pauline viardot et de
réaménager les intérieurs fermé au
public pour raisons de sécurité depuis
nous avons de très beaux décors peints
qui sont typiques de cette fin du 19e
siècle
il faut les restaurer ils sont en très
mauvais état nous espérons pouvoir
reconstituer au premier étage les
appartements de louis pauline viardot ce
qui serait aussi une façon de se
retrouver dans l'ambiance de cette
époque
coût total du projet 3,1 millions
d'euros la ville a bénéficié d'un coup
de pouce de 500000 euros de la part du
loto du patrimoine lancé par stéphane
bern en 2018
d'autres mécènes et notamment la région
ont mis la main au portefeuille
si la navarre évidemment par les
personnes extraordinaires qui y vécurent
tourguéniev grands auteurs russes à
pauline viardot et et bizet qui est mort
ici qui a composé carmen ici et qui a
une vie profondément fin très très
difficile et qu'ici à peut-être trouvé
le havre de paix qui lui manquait dans
une vie tumultueuse et douloureuse
la livraison est prévue le 18 juillet
2021 jour du bicentenaire de la
naissance de la compositrice une fois
restauré le site sera transformé en
centre européen de la musique et espère
attirer plusieurs milliers de visiteurs
lui justement est passionné de vieilles
pierres mais aussi de bien plus récent
bon soir cédric l'apport vous êtes le
directeur d'une agence immobilière à
villepreux créateur du blog immobilier
et des pros et vous avez lancé liens non
une chaîne youtube spécialisée sur
l'immobilier vous y donner des conseils
sur le métier je vous propose tout de
suite de regarder un extrait d'une vidéo
alors le point numéro un c'est aimer
alors aimer marcel proust disait dans la
vie ce qui est important ce n'est pas ce
qu'on aime c'est d'aimer et je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec ça dans la
vie ce qui est important c'est vraiment
des mais aimer ce qu'on fait aimer ses
relations avec les clients et met son
travail mais pour aimer vous allez me
dire ok cédric mais comment est ce qu'on
fait pour développer cette compétence
pourrait mais pour être passionné par
son travail
bon bah déjà savait tout de suite si
vous aimez les gens vous savez tout de
suite si vous aimez vendre de base
vous savez si vous allez à peu près
aimez votre métier ensuite après vous
allez vous fixez des objectifs quand
vous allez démarrer dans votre métier en
vous fixant des objectifs vous allez
tout de suite voir si si si ça vous
épanouie si vous êtes heureux dans votre
travail
et en plus de ça vous allez fêter vos
réussites et mais pour vous c'est la
première des qualités à avoir pour un
agent immobilier pourquoi justement
oui parce que c'est un métier qui
demande énormément d'énergie énormément
de d'implication et ça me paraît évident
que si on n'aime pas les hommes les yeux
des humains si on n'aime pas ce qu'on
fait naturellement on sera pas bon la
transmission pour vous donner des
conseils au travers ces vidéos c'est
quelque chose qui vous tient à coeur
oui tout à fait alors j'avais cette
problématique de le faire pour mes
collaborateurs et puis je me suis dit
bon bah autant autant le faire de
manière plus large et j'ai commencé avec
un ami qui s'appelle mathieu bilou et
qui habite également sur le 78 à créer
ces vidéos larmes et en fait c'est pas
le coeur de mon essai de mon écosystèmes
sains youtube c'est vraiment un outil le
coeur de l'écosystème c'est le blog qui
est le blog immobilier des pros ou jeu
fourni des conseils où je donne des
astuces aux professionnels de
l'immobilier pour pour développer leur
activité et puis pour le vivre bien
alors justement me disais à l'origine
c'était des vidéos consacrées en tout
cas destinés à vos employés pourquoi
utiliser justement le moyen de la vidéo
pourquoi c'est plus ludique que de
simples conseils on va dire de vis-à-vis
pourquoi utiliser la vidéo
le gros intérêt de la vidéo qu'on va
enregistrer c'est que derrière on va
pouvoir
fournir ce contenu à différentes
personnes le dupliquer c'est un contenu
qui va rester en place demain j'ai un
collaborateur qui
qui ne se souvient plus de ce que je lui
ai dit il ya deux semaines et bien si
c'est dans la vidéo il suffit de cliquez
sur play et moi j'ai pas besoin de me
répéter de redire la même chose c'est du
contenu qui reste comment dire kiné qui
ne se jette pas à la poubelle en fait
tout ce que je vais mettre sur le blog
généralement c'est pas de l'actualité
donc ce sont des choses qu'on va pouvoir
réutiliser en permanence plus que c'est
difficile de combiner justement
l'activité de youtuber d'animateurs d'un
bloc d'un blog sur l'immobilier et aussi
la fonction de directeur d' agences
alors saleh
mais ça l'est moins à partir du moment
où on délègue on sait déléguer les
activités à ses collaborateurs et c'est
ce qui m'a permis en fait de pouvoir
développer le blog c'est d'avoir pu
m'appuyer sur des collaborateurs qui
sont capables compétents et qui
fournissent un excellent travail et les
sujets vous les choisissez comment est
ce que c'est votre communauté qui vous
suggère des idées de sujets ce que c'est
vos propres idées
alors effectivement la communauté
m'apporte énormément de réponses en fait
vous avez également les requêtes quand
on va sur google sur youtube et bien on
voit quels sont les sujets qui touchent
le plus les gens donc par exemple dans
l'immobilier ce qui impacte plus les
collaborateurs c'est comment on va
réussir à prospecter donc le mot
prospecter il faut que j'utilise dans
dans mes titres et dans tout ce que je
vais développer après sur youtube sur
les réseaux sociaux et sur mon blog
combien de temps ça prend en moyenne de
produire une vidéo même si on imagine
chaque vidéo et est différente mais à
peu près combien de temps alors j'écris
un scénario qui est un article à la base
et pour ça il faut à peu près une
journée pour écrire un bon article
ensuite il nous faut avec mathieu une
demi journée pour le tourner et lui
après il a facilement deux journées de
travail pour monter la vidéo avec
notamment ce cet appareil reflex avec
lequel vous êtes venus qui vous sert à
faire ces vidéos c'est finalement une
cible très précises ce sont les
professionnels de l'immobilier vos
vidéos tournent autour de 200 300 vues
il y en a certaines qui monte au dessus
des 1000 2000 vue du coup le quel est
l'objectif
alors exactement donc là en ce moment on
la chaîne est vraiment en train de
monter de manière comment dire très
puissante
on a de plus en plus d'abonnés on a plus
en plus de personnes qui viennent laïcs
et les vidéos
donc l'intérêt pour moi c'est de pouvoir
ramener les gens vers vers mon blog
d'accord à l'objectif à terme c'est
monétiser cette vidéo tu as fait
l'objectif c'est de monétiser ses vidéos
et de proposer des formations en
e-learning parce que ça c'est un projet
que vous avez en tête une plateforme
ouvrir une plateforme de yale e-learning
payante fs quelque chose qui devrait
arriver d'ici le début 2001 les
prochaines vidéos qu'on pourra retrouver
sur la page dès la semaine prochaine si
on fait bien notre travail on a toujours
été régulier donc là normalement mardi
matin 8h nouvelle vidéo en ligne sur mon
ascension du kilimandjaro
je reviens du kilimandjaro et j'ai
réussi à atteindre le sommet à 5895 m et
bien bravo et on retrouve vos vidéos sur
la chaîne youtube qui porte votre nom
c'est à dire cédric laporte merci d'être
venus en plateau merci grêlons pour la
fin des vacances de la toussaint les
vrais gourmands ou du rendez-vous ont un
rendez vous incontournable c'est le
salon du chocolat c'est pendant cinq
jours à cette occasion christophe
bertrand de l'aréna street dans les
yvelines a créé une robe en chocolat
elle a été portée hier par une
journaliste lors de la soirée
d'ouverture marylène iapichino et manon
varaldo reviennent sur l'événement ce
sont les 25 ans du salon du chocolat et
pour cette soirée inaugurale un défilé
de robes en chocolat est organisé par
ton dans les coulisses
les exposants terminent leur dernière
installation sur leur stand du chocolat
sous toutes ses formes des oursons des
tablettes mais aussi des créations en
chocolat
le salon du chocolat est international
il regroupe vingt pays producteurs je me
trouve actuellement dans les coulisses
33 vont être portés et présenté lors de
cette soirée inaugurale les créateurs
s'affairent pour profit n'est les
derniers détails de ces trente rome avec
des thèmes différents
dans les coulisses et des créations
parfois surprenantes comme celle ci avec
hazeaux
la gourmandise est l'art s'entremêlent
elizabeth tchoungui va porter la robe en
chocolat réalisées par une équipe de
trois artisans réunis par la reine
astrid
je retrouve nicolas morin de la reine
astrid qui s'est occupé de la partie
chocolat pour cette robe alors justement
parlez moi un petit peu de cette robe
qui va être portées par la journaliste
franco camerounaise alors déjà cette
robe on a voulu c'est de mettre en avant
ce qu'on peut retrouver au cameroun et
des idées des l'esprit un peu comme on
est donc on a travaillé des matières
brutes et des matières plus dorée on a
voulu à travers cette robe montrer un
petit peu ben voilà partis chocolat mais
la partie brut du chocolat elizabeth
tchoungui se prépare à enfiler cette
création une fierté pour elle c'est avec
beaucoup d'émotion et de plaisir que
j'ai accepté ce défilé parce que la
reine astrid travaille avec des
cultivateurs de cacao du cameroun or mon
père est camerounais mon grand-père
cultiver le cacao est donc c'est une
vraie fierté pour moi de porter
aujourd'hui les couleurs du cacao que
mes cousins continue de cultiver dans le
village de mon père
beaucoup nous servir
l'ouverture du défilé s'est faite avec
le groupe kalema deux frères originaires
de sao tomé et principe et lille cacao
le salon du chocolat mais les pays
producteurs à l'honneur avec des robes
en chocolat
on se retrouve sur le stand de la reine
astrid juste après le défilé d'elizabeth
tchoungui
ce sont des mois de préparation
satisfait du résultat satisfait oui mais
c'est beaucoup de préparation la
braderie on le voit pas mais c'est 200
heures de travail donc c'est un truc
énorme comme la reine astrid 229
exposants sont présents pour la 25e
édition du salon du chocolat
comme tous les mercredis petit tour dans
nos salles de cinéma saint-quentinoise
direction ce soir l'ugc skywest agi
moisins d'halloween patrick jacques de
dixmude et nicolas landry sont allés
recueillir quelques à quelques avis en
sortie du jour à une sortie du jour
retour à zombieland c'est la suite est
de zombieland un peu de frisson mais
surtout beaucoup d'humour regarder
[Musique]
c'est l'heure de se la péter ou de la
boucle est très bons films en tout cas
dans la continuité du premier donc
beaucoup d'humour et vraiment je suis
ravi c'est drôle j'ai déjà vu le premier
alors dix ans se sont écoulés depuis
l'apocalypse zombie cette famille
dysfonctionnelle joie tu veux savoir ce
que j'aimerais je m'en contrefous deux
de tes frères a survécu en faisant
preuve de discernement
il traduit pour la survie
allez encore en vie parce que les
zombies selon risque cervelle et que le
rien dans le crâne
les personnages sont hyper sympa c'est
pas trop grand pour les enfants et ben
non mais c'est le dialogue qui sont
rigolos les situations c'était marrant
mais ça fait pas donc trop peur et bas
les personnages y sont attachants vieux
messieurs tout petit il n'est plus là il
est très limité voici là ça ne fait pas
peur non non c'est bon et un peu de gore
comme parce que c'est un film de zombies
mais c'est très très très drôle à la
fois on pense que c'est sérieux mais non
ce n'est pas du tout sérieux c'est
vraiment de la déconne jusqu'à la fin
[Musique]
crête janvier
et si vous n'avez pas encore d'idée de
déguisement de décoration pour halloween
rassurez-vous miquel et demi d'euros et
mathilde et demi se sont rendus dans une
boutique spécialisée à maurepas
[Musique]
halloween ce jeudi à 31 octobre si vous
n'avez pas encore didier de déguisements
nous allons vous en proposer c'est parti
quelles sont les grandes tendances de
cette année a pour la wind pour nous
aiguiller océane est à mes côtés elle
est vendeuse dans ce magasin maurepas
alors quelles sont les grosses tendances
déjà chez les enfants chez les enfants
cette année on a pour les jeunes filles
le déguisement de sorcière le
traditionnel on a plein de modèles en
magasin du coup et pour les jeunes
hommes du coup ce sera le déguisement de
qnd donc combinaisons et masques
ça fait peur ça fait peur alors au
niveau des accessoires aussi on peut
customiser sa tenue pour le web c'est
exactement comme par exemple on a des
serre têtes qui serre tête de diable on
a du maquillage du latex du faux sang du
la crème de maquillage on a des masques
en latex de la laque pour cheveux aussi
est le meilleur bas les lentilles on a
des différents types de l'envié en
magasin bon je vais tester tout ça je
vais me promener dans la boutique
ouais je sais trop un déguisement pour
halloween y'a pas de problème
[Musique]
alors si on n'aime pas se déguiser pour
halloween est ce qu'il ya quand même la
possibilité de fêter cette fête
oui absolument vous pouvez faire par
exemple des tables ont prix moyen d'une
table c'est à peu près 60 euros en
comptant le nappage le chemin de table
les assiettes sûr il va de quelques
décorations sur la table vous pouvez
mettre par exemple des doigts on a des
doigts et doigts coupés
ça fait peur ça fait fred haslin vient
on a des petites bougies des petites
bougies à l'aide s'ils voulaient mettre
des petites bougies à l'aide
on a les serviettes les gobelets en fait
c'est un ensemble qu'on fait avec tout
le package en fait
[Musique]
ici dans cette boutique on vend autant à
halloween qu'à noël ou au jour de l'an
moi j'ai trouvé mon costume espérons que
ça vous êtes inspiré voilà c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
dans un instant et nouveau numéro du 7 8
sociétés manon varaldo et ses invités
parleront du sujet du bizutage c'est
dans un instant belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]